6 24 in your monday morning this is a
heads up about losing freeway lanes
during the day in henderson a lot of
times these things are overnight but
this is going to be during the day
nevada department of transportation
taking away the right lane of both
directions on the i-11 between horizon
and college now that's not a huge
stretch but the hours seven
this morning until five this evening
today tomorrow and on wednesday as well
man that could add brake lights and
headaches to both the morning and
afternoon rush hours you'll also be
losing the right shoulders of the
freeway ramps at horizon and college the
good news it is guard rail painting
that's part of the final phase of
upgrades to this part of i-11 maybe you
didn't catch all of this you want to go
over it again whatever all of our
driving you crazy stories are on our
eight newsnow.com website when you click
traffic then driving you crazy buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone something's driving you crazy
email me traffic eight at eight
newsnow.com